this say the ukrainians is the
destruction of an arms depot it's
thought u.s supplied high mars rockets
were launched at the site in the
russian-controlled region of kirsan the
ukrainians say 52 russian soldiers were
also killed but the moscow-backed
authorities claim it was a fertilizer
store and seven civilians have died al
jazeera cannot independently confirm
either claim
pictures taken in the daylight give some
idea of the damage caused the u.s has
been rushing missile systems to ukraine
believing they can help push back
russian forces one u.s senator urged
congress to send more and send them
quickly when people understandably ask
about our support for ukraine our
taxpayer funded aid to the tune of
billions of dollars
they deserve to know
that their hard-earned taxpayer dollars
are being spent wisely
in my view that means spending it on
weapons like highmars that are actually
making a difference
on the battlefield the russians are
believed to be in an operational pause
in the east of the country ready to push
on and take the rest of the donbass
region the pause is to restock refuel
and resupply but that becomes much more
difficult if the ukrainians are able to
target and successfully destroy
ammunition dumps
some analysts say the rocket system
could significantly delay russian
progress the ukrainian president says
he's glad to have them
i want to thank the united states of
america for its decision to provide
ukraine with a new 400 million dollar
defense assistance package
additional highmars and other precision
weapons allow us to take anti-terrorist
steps they allow us to reduce russian
strikes with their missiles on our
people
but the us believes the russians are
also restocking turning to the iranians
for uavs or unmanned drones our
information indicates that the iranian
government
is preparing to provide russia with up
to several hundred uavs including
weapons-capable uavs on an
expedited timeline
the u.s insists moscow has failed in its
main strategic objectives in ukraine but
those in the east are bracing themselves
for a major russian offensive that could
come in just days alan fisher al jazeera
keeve